do not
hello welcome to a new edition of
the women tech makers this time
edition we are also in the offices
google in the googleplex in one place
what's called the garage this place is a
place where hackers and creative people from
google comes to do magical things and I
It is very nice to present three
excellent women from latin america who
are with us and are winners of
different groups of google developers
bus an event we did in america
Latina between October and December of the year
passed in four cities of america
latina and they represent three of the
four winning teams from Argentina
colombia and brazil mexico unfortunately
he only had one team with names but I
It's great to present them I'm going to
ask some basic questions and
welcome to wintek makers
well what do you think if we start with
something basic and each one tells us how
they found out about the event they were doing before
to get to the google developers and how
they came to that event
a man had the esso designer and without
move they confront their vision words I
I have a small company to create
projects online is responsible
by heading and google + a city
of soccer when day 2 christian
benitez let this be a dinner
of the long and schuster is worth more than 25 and
we create a project very relegated about
fitness and doing that after the end of
abc program
let's go with the concert project
hello my name is Andrea mame her
representative of the colombia team and
what he did before the duel for you was
I am work in the commercial part a
chemical company let's say that my
contact with technology had not been
quite broad I got the mail
because I'm registered more in the part
as entrepreneurship beyond
technology came to us an email
we wrote that it was a process of
different filters filters by internet
and then a physical filter already in Bogota and
It has been an incredible experience
get here to know we see that
all this entrepreneurial environment and
technological has been quite
enriching
hello my name is catarina partner of
argentina good one month before more or less
before the google contest alone
had been with a project and there was
google at the doors of argentina and
well I wanted to take you the project and
as good I could not enter because I said the
I did not know anyone there I was
getting into forums and google stuff
I found out about the contest between there were several
filters as my partner said so
when I was the competition and we won
with my equipment the machine could create it
it was like a dream come true is
great because one makes you think that
really when you want something with
much strength and with much desire
you can really achieve it and that google
is open those opportunities is like
what does it do to you to create it much more and
nothing we are here and extremely happy and
proud to be the representatives of
our countries
thanks, what do you think if we talk about a
little more about how they imagined that
it was going to be the competition they felt
when they won and what they did
specifically within each of
your projects to bring your equipment to
this triumph then talk
briefly what does the project do for
favor
a project an application learn to
differentiate trains from academia like
identification elements
he never works in a game
identification account a prize was a
great challenge because learning so much with
just three days is one thing that I
it helped a lot went to the documentation of
android to be very complete the
central and all three networks is
decorated and sent the agency highlighted
pretty explanatory to create
professional and teaching presentations
our voucher was super I started and
here we are
well my project was max point and the
idea of ​​match point is mainly
make small businesses the
entrepreneurs do not have to deal with
those activities that are not the core
of your business if you are a bakery and
you your job is to make bread you would not have
why deal so much with the part of
lawyers with the marketing part
we have what we intend
on the platform is that specialists
know that these activities are done by
those entrepreneurs and so on
devote your time more to things
important my role within the group was
mainly the project manager is
say at the end of each day they were or was a
three-day event and at the end of each
day what we did was that we made a
pitch that is more or less a speech one
to the sale of the idea and my function
main was how to approach the idea how
develop it in a way that was more
in Spanish for all the people who
were not just like the side
technological but that I had as a
look much closer to the people and
Well, very happy at the moment
we won it was a great experience and so
a spectacular prize me that we have
well my role logically was designed
but at the same time
I do not know how a woman was like something different
because it was like the vision of a woman
within the group and the truth that touched me
a group beyond that there are fights
internal to each other but from
joke the truth that we were a team that
is the principle we join the three
days a house we follow the marathon of
night we were recontra focused on what
what we wanted to do and we had something left
spectacular and it is record we attend very
proud of when mission we won
and we could not believe it and well we
we find everyone here today and with lives
to follow this project good as
all the groups that we earn the same as
you can notice we are in the garage and there
a spontaneous concert at this time
for all developer visitors
box then
let's continue though a little bit of
noise will ask you to speak a
little bit stronger but I want to want
continue this conversation with your
expectations how they look after the
experience of the level or by you that
they think it's different and I would like
top with something a little bit deeper
that they believe is necessary for the
women in their communities follow
doing technological things and go into
this world of entrepreneurship
creativity development
for me it has been an experience
amazing
I opened my head
of the whole world of technology and
creativity today
after google for me it was a
show without being able to see all respect and has
been the last double basically went to
my joint perspective to give ideas
new and put into practice to grow
increasingly as a professional he confessed
when to the community without competitors
There are female nurses
brazil iwasaki
is Real Madrid and no more vision more
creative of the world you take it home
the local channel 5 manager is missing
practice knowledge and time is
will get acquired without arrival to
Internet
information books palestras competitions and
services you know and busses and sign did
the time was treated way be you
to actively deal with
Christ project climate jump
Well, as a woman, my special
it is mainly to realize a
very different world
ok initially because I do not have a
background in the technological part
then get to a place of google
for me it was going to be a place like more than
engineers more than programmers like
something much farther from my reality and the
made to get to a place and if
you discover many things and it's a world
new is in many ways a language
different if it's a very accessible place and
it's a question that many of us have
very afraid of technology like what
we see very distant as something that does not happen
to our countries or not our
means and it is more to see it as something that is
very close and from which you can learn
very easy and that there is a quantity of
group clubs tools
sessions and activities that can
help and that you can enter as a
this world of technology then
let's say that in the part as of
technological environment for women
mainly as more events equal
let's say that if now with the experience
to be as you are as more spokesperson as
what can you tell many people
experience of what you lived that
it really is a world that if you can
enter and it's a world that is open and
that you are have many possibilities
in which you can participate then
it's like more events more involvement
of different women not only for
the technological ones but also as
in any other field
good and my message for women
He is also justly told with me
experience the fact that
for me it is what I get from the
you tried this thing of what is rich that
is the complement or the fact of
can learn so much from a programmer
as another person who does not dedicate us
specifically what I do is like
that you learn and we see a lot a lot a lot
not only in my group but from other groups
and this is exactly what I want
convey women right that they do not
it's a thing that if it's better or worse if
who is better men to women
break this rivalry and start
see what everyone really has as their
positive aspect and that we can contribute
much from each place and just this
gender difference makes nothing that
we have two very good things and each one
it stands out well stored something else and
just supplement this to get
to something much richer among all
thank you very well well there you have it
three successful women in this case in the
developer voice part of women tekniker and
we are waiting for you in the next edition
see you soon
yes